like you can bring those anywhere keep
them in your glove Department keep them
in your purse I'm like do you have one
on you right now because you keep
talking about
yeah break up snack foods how many
breakups have you been to the room
so sorry that really hit home
wish I've been through more
maybe meet
plus door so let's get to it first up oh
my goodness oh classic I'm ready for it
everyone knows that there's two types of
candy chocolate and not chocolate you
gotta hit both food groups I can't just
be wolfing down some M M's without
having like also a sour candy does that
make sense so which one do I eat first
in my household we alternate these are
dangerous because like once you start
you can't stop and that's okay like if
the breakup didn't have those tears like
that'll bring the tears for sure I have
a few questions wow my strategy is to
mask the Pain by hurting myself in
another way it gets my mind off things
yeah just now when I was eating them
like I completely mission accomplished
yeah I'm not mad at it all right we'll
see we'll see tell me a little bit about
chocolate peanut butter pie Oreo so
they're creamy get the peanut butter you
get like a little pie and the cake and
it's just like a really nice dessert
there are like nine different methods
right now that I'm thinking of eating
this
oh baby that's the peanut butter that's
for sure and there's the chocolate makes
sense with the colors I'm about to say
something and it's good news I honestly
like these better than a normal Oreo
I really do when going through a breakup
I feel like this is the perfect snack
because obviously it's crunchy it's
creamy I don't know if I could eat all
of this and like wake up the next
morning I could see myself sobbing into
these for sure are we swapping or are we
keeping well I really do really like the
whole sour thing accompanied by the
peanut chocolate thank you I'm gonna
have to go with my snack feels homey and
cozy and it's what I know this was good
though but I'm going back with mine I
respect it I would too in terms of like
breakup you're so right something about
creamy flavor gives me a breakup are we
ready for the next round oh I'm ready
let's do it
okay let's see it let's go
obviously it's Taco Bell I haven't had
one of these since College I haven't had
one since like three days ago
Uncrustables oh baby so I'll go first
here did I just pick this up and bite
this it's been a while absolutely if I
saw you with a fork and knife I'd tackle
you to the ground oh my gosh your
Crunchwrap Supreme get rid of the beef
add chicken instead add jalapenos and
also fire in Diablo sauce at the same
time do you like spicy things I do it's
the spice or the breakup that's perfect
that's actually nice I think you I
didn't make it but thank you why don't
you really enjoy this you think of
breakup Foods I immediately go to like
an ice cream or like some dessert kind
of thing but like I gotta be sobbing
during dinner too the beautiful thing
about a Crunchwrap is that you can eat
it and cry wherever you want whether
that is in the car as soon as you leave
that drive through but me personally I
would say on my couch wrapped in a
blanket in the comfort of my own home so
I'm not kind of being judged by those
around me do I try your own crustable
yes these are my Uncrustables these are
peanut butter and strawberry jelly that
is an important detail you have to have
them cold they are a perfect like 2 A.M
kind of snack when like the tears just
and like you just need something quick
and fast I mean you can't beat it it's
really it's really good all right so
what are we gonna do are we gonna swap
are we gonna keep it
okay this is really hard for me these
are like two different foods to me but I
think I have to go with the Crunchwrap
Supreme I mean it's like it's a
Crunchwrap Supreme what more can be said
I'm not gonna lie this was like really
nostalgic I actually forgot how good
this was and I feel like it would be a
nice replacement
so I am actually going to keep this one
super tasty okay should we do the next
one let's do it let's do it can I keep
this snack number three
Mom oh whoa
wow interesting don't knock it till you
try it that is a dill pickle not a sweet
pickle get out of town if you like sweet
pickles would you like sweet pickles I
do no okay great what is this doing for
you oh it's doing a lot for me in every
oh yeah that was such a good bite again
like you were saying with the Oreo you
can just wolf down like truly a full jar
and not feel bad well you'd feel bad
about the breakup still probably but I
just love a good pickle they're so juicy
you get that salt how many of these are
you eating in one sitting do you have to
be honest probably like eight I feel
like that's not as many as it sounds
when you're going through a breakup I
feel like I need something from every
food group you need that sweet you need
that savory and this kind of hits one of
the other food groups yeah I could see
that I really do like the dill and
pickle there we go yeah I'm open can I
try your paws of course how do you eat
it are you grabbing by the fist I mean
yeah I'm fisting these people oh baby
here we go
obviously when you're going through a
breakup you're looking for anything to
just like distract you and get your mind
off of things so like the shape like
really is a little bit entertaining I
totally agree with you just like having
a little fun thing it's like and I look
down and I go okay there's a brief
moment of levity I like submitted an
income
flavor they haven't got back to at
Cheetos you submitted an inquiry yeah I
love that so what are you gonna do are
you sticking with your snack are you
sticking with the dill pickle thingy you
know as much as I love a pickle I'm
gonna have to go with the Puffs this
just feels more breakupy like holding
this here
what about you what are you keeping well
I love the pickle it's not giving
breakup sad depressed so
and I respect that yeah are you gonna
finish that one not bad okay thank you
let's do the next round let's do it
ready yes ready yes
my goodness whoa a honey bun I don't
think I've had a honey bun oh my
goodness
it looks to me like a cinnamon
or something like that
oh baby are you kidding me this is the
breakfast morning breakup snack this is
like before I pretend like I'm gonna go
work out I'm gonna eat a bite of that
have a little coffee this is wild
because I like one bite and it's it's
melting in my mouth they're like super
small and compact so you can put them in
like your shirt your sweater and your
hair okay do these come wrapped I now
have to ask yeah they do come around
great and you're so right I need to be
sobbing at breakfast too yeah and this
is the perfect way to do it portable
like you can bring those anywhere keep
them in your glove Department keep them
in your purse like do you have one on
you right now because you keep talking
about
gone very crazy dark chocolate so these
are in the freezer section at Trader
Joe's TJ's does it again they really do
they done did it again are you a dark
chocolate kind of person
yes
I am you look like you just got over the
breakup I'll tell you what I actually
really love these this is like okay I'm
over it I'm done yes it reminds me of
what's to come it's not healthy but like
we're getting there I mean I'm not
talking about dark chocolate to me and
my lived experience healthy a strawberry
that's what we call a fruit are we
swapping or are we keeping what do you
want to do I'm gonna keep it real honey
buns like I grew up on those I just feel
like I've surpassed that I'm ready to
give them up oh I did not expect that I
think that I also am gonna go with the
berry berry okay very very very
see you get so confused when trying to
say the name of it that you forget about
your ex next one are you ready let's do
it come on oh my gosh that's the cutest
thing I've ever seen chocolate milk is
this what this is not chocolate milk
chocolate milk I can't say that I'm
super excited about this one if I'm
gonna be honest so like what's the deal
you gotta remember that like snack is
not only food form I gotta be drinking
something while I'm wolfing down on my
drumsticks you know
um bizarre it's kind of thick isn't it
yeah it's like a viscous fluid but it's
delicious all right I accept that um how
about we try the cone okay you do what
you want I usually eat a few of these at
a time so this is like okay I'm going to
binge watch my favorite series and I'm
gonna eat like 10 of these you don't
feel bad about eating like 50 of them
and again I am distracted by how cute
and fun they are yeah I don't even
remember my ex all right so what are we
gonna do are we gonna swap or are we
gonna keep it obviously I think you know
where I'm at all right I'm eyeing my
cones what are you doing what are you
doing I'm okay this is hard I'm trying
to look back at all the other snacks
that I've had and again I kind of am
standing by the fact that you need a
liquid so I think I'm gonna go with the
liquid okay but these are delicious okay
that was all of them this was so fun
though thank you all for joining us and
let us know what your favorite breakup
snack food is yeah comment below tell us
thanks for hanging out with us thank you
bye you're gonna get through this you
are don't worry okay we've all been
there you're better off without them
[Music]
yeah
foreign
[Music]
[Music]